Bonjour, ici Steve Kaufmann.
Aujourd'hui, je veux vous parler
de la langue française.
Au sujet de la langue française, est
ce que le français est difficile ?
Si vous aimez mes vidéos, veuillez cliquer
sur la cloche pour avoir des notifications
et puis si vous me suivez
sur un service de podcast.
Veuillez laisser un commentaire s'il vous plait.
Bon, de mon avis, le français...
Pour quelqu'un qui parle déjà
l'anglais n'est pas très difficile
parce que dans l'apprentissage
de n'importe quelle langue,
la chose la plus importante
pour moi, c'est le vocabulaire.
Alors, le vocabulaire en français est assez
semblable au vocabulaire en anglais.
60% à peu près des mots sont d'origine française
ou du moins reconnaissable comme étant
semblable aux mots du vocabulaire anglais.
Bon, par exemple, les mots que
je vais utilisés dans cette vidéo.
La plupart, vous pouvez
reconnaître que ce sont des mots
qui sont semblables à des mots en anglais.
Si vous allez étudier cette
vidéo comme leçon à LingQ
ce que vous pouvez faire parce que
cette vidéo sera dans la bibliothèque
de la langue française à LingQ
Vous pouvez voir, vous pouvez sauvegarder
des mots qui sont, vous allez le voir
très semblable à l'anglais, donc
les mots sont très semblables.
Grand avantage!
Et même des fois, il faut savoir
que quand il y a un accent aigu,
c'est à dire comme ça, ou un
accent circonflexe en français
ça cache un S, donc, "Etudier= Study"
"Ecole = School"
"Hôtel=Hostel"
Donc, il y a un tas d'exemples où l'accent
cache un X, un S par exemple, pardon...
Donc, cela peut vous aider à reconnaître
des mots que vous connaissez déjà.
Même chose pour ceux qui
parlent l'italien ou l'espagnol.
Mais il y a... Par exemple le mot
"Parola" en italien existe en français
Mais en français, ça veut dire... C'est
comme les paroles dans une chanson
ou bien "Je vous donne la
parole" = "Je vous promets."
Donc, il y a des fois des fausses amis
mais ça n'empêche pas que
le fait qu'il y a tellement de mots
qu'on reconnaît de l'anglais,
de l'italien, de l'espagnol.
Ça aide beaucoup dans
l'apprentissage du français.
Bon, par contre, l'écriture est très différente
En espagnol, chaque lettre a une signification
Enfin, en tant que ce que ça
représente comme prononciation.
C'est très simple, c'est très
clair et c'est très régulier.
Ce n'est pas le cas en français; donc,
le mot "Eau" par exemple, "Mot" M-O-T.
"Beau" B-E-A-U, ou même avec un X,
il y a un tas d'exemples comme ça
où, finalement, il faut s'habituerà l'écriture.
Mais je crois que l'orthographe
en français quand même
est plus régulier qu'en anglais, alors que...
Cependant, il y a des utilisations de lettres,
façon d'écrire très différentes
de l'anglais ou de l'espagnol
Donc, c'est un problème,
mais il faut s'y habituer.
Et c'est uniquement en lisant
beaucoup, en écoutant beaucoup
en lisant et en regardant
la valeur des lettres en français.
On va s'y habituer, bon...
Autre difficulté en français,
c'est la prononciation.
D'abord, parce qu'il y a
des sons comme "U"
Il faut s'habituer à prononcer ce son et ça
prend du temps. Ça prend du temps.
Et les sons nasaux, "On" "An" "En" "Un".
Il faut s'habituer.
Et quand on n'est pas habitué à ces sons
ça rend la compréhension un peu plus difficile.
Ensuite, il y a le phénomène
de la liaison, c'est à dire:
Si je dis "Temps" T-E-M-P-S, "Temps"
c'est à dire "Time" or "Weather" en anglais.
Si on dit "De temps en temps", alors là,
"Temps" qui était "Temps",
devient "TempZ en Temps"
Donc, le "S" se prononce et est même
lié "liaison", lié au mot suivant.
Et ça, on le remarque partout en français.
Et c'est une autre chose
à laquelle il faut s'habituer.
Et on a beau savoir que ça existe,
mais tout de même, chaque fois qu'on
entend cette liaison, ce n'est pas très clair.
Si ce son là appartient au mot
précédent ou au mot suivant
Ceux sont des choses auxquelles il faut s'habituer.
Autre chose, je crois, qui rend
la langue française un peu difficile
C'est le genre, c'est à dire masculin ou féminin.
Ça n'existe pas en anglais, bien que ça existe
en italien et dans beaucoup de langues
Et alors qu'en italien ou un espagnol
Souvent les mots qui se terminent
par un "O" sont masculins
et qui terminent par un "A" sont
féminins et ça nous donne des...
On peut deviner un peu
le genre de ces mots là.
En français, c'est moins clair.
Donc on dit grammaire et ça, c'est féminin,
mais on dit commentaire et ça, c'est masculin.
Et donc, ce n'est pas aussi évident.
Alors là aussi, c'est une
question d'habitude et il faut...
Il faut accepter qu'on va continuer à faire
des fautes dans le genre comme je le fais.
Je continue à le faire, mais ça
n'empêche pas la communication.
Autre chose en français, c'est les verbes.
Il y a beaucoup de verbes irréguliers,
et il y a beaucoup de temps.
Il y a même un temps qui n'est pas utilisé dans
le langage oral et uniquement utilisé dans l'écrit
c'est à dire le passé simple.
Si on lit beaucoup, on s'y habitue très vite.
Aujourd'hui, par exemple, si
vous étudiez le français à LingQ
Vous pouvez chercher dans les
dictionnaires que nous avons.
Il y a plusieurs dictionnaires qui offrent...
C'est à dire des dictionnaires de conjugaison
et chaque fois que vous
voyez une forme d'un verbe
vous pouvez chercher pour savoir
quel temps, quelle personne, etc.
Alors là, ça aide la tâche.
Mais finalement, il faut uniquement...
Enfin, il faut continuer à lire à beaucoup écouter
et à lire pour que le cerveau puisse s'habituer.
Alors là, j'ai dit "pour que"
"afin que", "pour que" le cerveau
puisse s'adapter ou s'habituer.
Alors là, c'est le subjonctif
qui est aussi un aspect grammatical
qui existe dans plusieurs langues.
Non seulement les langues comme
le français, l'italien, l'espagnol
mais aussi dans d'autres langues,
même en persan, il y a le subjonctif
c'est à dire quand il y a une situation
de possibilité ou d'incertitude.
On utilise une forme du verbe
qui est bien spécifique.
Il faut... Il faut l'apprendre,
il faut s'y habituer.
Je vais vous laisser un nom... Pour
ce qui concerne la prononciation
qui cause des difficultés et de
prononciation et de compréhension.
Et j'ai une petite chanson de Georges
Brassens que je considère très utile.
Pour s'habituer à la prononciation
et la compréhension du français
parce que plusieurs des sons
"nasaux" y apparaissent
ainsi que le son "E" parce qu'en français
Quand le "E" n'a pas d'accent, s'est prononcé
"E" et souvent ce n'est pas prononcé,
Surtout si ce son apparaît à la fin des mots.
Mais on peut toujours le prononcer et...
Cette chanson qui s'appelle
"Le p'tit cheval blanc."
Donc, on peut dire "Le petit cheval blanc"
ou "Le p'tit cheval blanc."
Et c'est "Cheval", ce n'est pas "Chéval", c'est "Cheval
blanc", "Le p'tit cheval blanc", "Blanc", "Temps"
Il y a un tas de sons "nasaux" qui
apparaissent dans cette chanson.
Et je vous propose de trouver les
paroles de cette chanson sur l'internet
L'importer à LingQ, écoutez la chanson
pour vous habituer au son nasal
et à d'autres sons qui sont en
particulier en français. Il faut...
Si la prononciation et la compréhension sont parmi
les plus importantes difficultés de la langue française
Bah, il faut se donner la possibilité de
développer des habitudes nouvelles.
Et une façon de le faire, c'est d'écouter
des chansons et même plusieurs plusieurs fois.
Et cette chanson de Brassens est très simple.
Et je vous recommande, donc, je vous propose
de l'écouter autant de fois que vous le pouvez
pour vous habituer à la prononciation du français.
Comme j'ai dit, le son sera disponible
dans la bibliothèque du français à LingQ.
Où vous pouvez l'étudier.
Et je vous souhaite bon courage, bonne chance,
dans l'apprentissage du français. Merci beaucoup!